[Applaudissements]
tu vois j'ai mis à annoncer qu on n'a
rien à voir
cette fois c'est y pas qui elle est
mathématicien et astronome consommation
mais elle s'interroge aussi la
philosophie
voilà qui n'a pas l'air très à l'aise
stressé quand même énormément je ne suis
pas de ceux de l'être cela me rassure un
peu
bonjour à toutes et à tous chers élèves
comme je vois qu'il ya de nombreux
nouveaux visages je vais me présenter je
m'appelle et pâtit je suis né ici
alexandre et en 355 comme sa faim entre
vous le savent déjà
je suis mathématicienne astronomes mais
également philosophe et plus
particulièrement néoplatonicienne avez
vous des questions quel jour on est
aujourd'hui 14 mai 415 et est-ce qu'il
ya des questions plus intéressante
ouais ce quoi ses droits ce néo les lacs
dans les mines dont vous parlez voyons
il s'agit pas courant philosophique que
le philosophe
qui comprend des idées des philosophes
grecs la dent d'ailleurs saviez vous que
platon a proposé une certaine égalité
entre hommes et femmes
ce philosophe considéré que les femmes
pouvaient réaliser les métiers que les
hommes eh bien tu attends s'il
consacrait une question très importante
qui reste toujours trop réponse à cette
question dans la nature on observe
pinard deux choses différentes par
exemple c'est à dire ceux craignant un
événement vous moi même toutes ces
choses forme une multiplicité
mais cette multiplicité doit bien
provenir quelque part d'une unité
c'est le problème du rapport entre
l'unité et la multiplicité comment la
multiplicité turrel at elle pu provenir
d'une seule unité
mon dieu cette femme simple mortel
détroit vicieuse il prétend découvrir
vérité grâce à son intelligence il
prétend tu sais pas découvrir des
mystères en se consacrant à la science
alors qu'on sait bien qu'elle se dise
qui a créé le monde et que le secret de
sa création divine ne sont la portée de
cas mortels et moins encore à la portée
d'une femme madame anna oui racontez là
pourquoi vous êtes devenu quoi bon comme
vous le savez déjà au moins j'espère
notre ville
alexandrie est une ville à l'origine
grecque qui suit ses propres traditions
grand culte à ses propres divinité et
qui a vu naître de nombreux ça depuis
longtemps
cette ville est dirigée par les romains
qui veut nous imposer le christianisme
en plus les chrétiens pas beaucoup les
sciences car cela se fait trop réfléchir
j'ai pas
mais moi voyez vous j'ai su philosophe
je me sens profondément même
amoureusement attirés par la région
je considère essentiel de préserver le
savoir et de cultiver l'esprit
scientifique car savoir c'est pouvoir et
c'est pour cela qu'il me semble très
important de comme j'ai dit avant
préserver la culture et les méthodes
grecque ainsi que de partager tous mes
connaissances mathématiques
astronomiques et bien sûr philosophique
quitte parce que certains chrétiens
m'accuse de paganisme ou de ne pas
croire en leurs deux uniques et voilà
pourquoi je suis devenu quoi la primaire
mais temps passe vite
ouais ok je raccompagne revient chez toi
mais mon père vient de m'appeler deux
années de cela c'est bien de me souviens
de s'échapper
je donne votre verre agora pour résoudre
le problème non ce n'est pas un problème
peut-être l'impression pas ouais ben ali
tu voulais poser une question non je
n'ai recevez-vous joue donc au bailliage
tabac
je ne supporte plus de cette histoire
mystique vous devez suivre la doctrine
chrétienne un dieu en ce lieu celui qui
connaît le sait les cris de sa création
divine ce châtiment
vous êtes alors en beauce et vous avez
bien mérité aux fameux qe2
[Musique]
je vais madame madame un professeur bien
aimé on se souviendra toujours du mal et
qu'il ne reste aucune trace écrite de
votre passage sur terre et oui
effectivement c'est une c'est une
stratégie de type i trop typique effacer
toute trace écrite
c'est le meilleur moyen de faire comme
si une personne n'avait jamais existé
et voilà une femme incroyable qu'on
attache et de rendre invisible
heureusement cette stratégie n'a jamais
fonctionné
et puis comme il bâtir d'autres
philosophes et d'autres femmes ont lutté
contre cela
comme par exemple simone de beauvoir au
20e siècle
[Musique]
votre au plateau de votre programme
préféré je serai autre présentateur ce
soit et je vais vous présenter en direct
live la somme parfaite
bon elle est jolie coq est toujours prêt
et rien que pour vous holmes elle sait
faire la vaisselle la lessive et en même
temps elle sait vous servir et bien sûr
c'est dans sa nature de nous servir
mais bon elle a des compléments et je
sais ce que vous pensez mais shirt et
l'expectative
elle va nous coûter cher en cadeau mais
vous savez elle sait mettre la table est
passé en dessous mais bon comme vous
savez c'est une femme et son rôle c'est
de garder
vous êtes enfant mais bon ya eu aussi
d'autres qualités comme
on est d'accord elles sont plus jolies
quentin 7 est bon des questions oui vous
êtes venez on vous écoute a su simone de
beauvoir simone à la fin de sa marque
remontée alors tu l'as fan de faire ça
je suis philosophe et romancière du 20e
siècle
et vous monsieur démontrer à quel point
personne n'est plus arrogant envers les
femmes plus agressif et méprisant la
même inquiet pour sa ville et il l'a
fait par fait que vous décrivez n'existe
que dans votre petite tête dr
car on ne naît pas femme on le devient
c'est la société qui nous fait devenir
cela n'a donc rien de naturel et c'est
en fait une excellente nouvelle ça veut
dire que rien ne nous oblige à nous
soumettre à cette autorité
alors
masculine qui vous dicte quoi faire en
effet car je ne suis pas un danger mais
pas un sujet au même titre que vous
autrement dit je n'ai pas d'essence les
rôles sociaux dans les deux femmes ne
dépendent pas du sexe mais déterminés
car biologique
c'est un lieu de détente de définir
quelles fins et ont réellement internet
mungiu les fin on peut rien leur dire
dès qu'on leur dit n'importe quoi elles
deviennent tout hystérique mais cesser
de traiter les femmes hystériques les
armes veulent toujours avoir raison et
croit alors pouvoir monopoliser le
pouvoir
mais oui c'est pour cela que la femme
est considérée comme le deuxième sexe en
marge de la société
bon il faut le dire une fois ci on les
sort de la cuisine
elles deviennent tout fun mais regardez
les ces deux folles qui savent rien
enfin mon dieu quel désastre
oh tu vois tu n'as pas le principe du
mariage et obscènes
car ils pensent aux droits et devoirs ce
qui devrait un échange qui devrait être
en somme qui devrait être fondée sur un
élan spontané mariage veut dire plus
d'obligation sociale en plus de corps
fait non merci
car si le mariage change les relations
que l'on a avec autrui comment ne
pourrait-il pas me changer
le couple je suis très bien comme je
suis je tiens à ma liberté
c'est pour cela que jamais de ma vie
je ne me marierai avec ça